and now you deserve 20K a month do you
guys live in absolute delusion what the
hell do you need 20K a month you it's so
funny I'm going to tell you what's so
funny what's so funny the richest people
I know don't live like that that that
are the most wealthy they don't need 20K
a month and it's these stupid well you
know honestly they have to be somewhat
smart to to pull this off but like it's
like these idiotic women that ruin it
for women that actually want traditional
outcomes ladies let's let's let's talk
to the tradition women out there the
women that want to be married that want
to be wives that want to be mothers we
need to start shaming this this this
stuff is so dead I'm so tired of seeing
it I'm so tired